behind the scenes at esa miyake's
fashion show in paris models used to
stand around backstage for hours with
nothing to do but that is changed I
don't go anywhere without my smartphone
is the new motto everyone is furiously
posting models like Adam amoli know that
these days no model can afford to ignore
Facebook much less Instagram will push
this wall you have to be very active and
post high quality content Betsy food
wheels it's important to interact with
your fans if you get a comment you need
to respond you can't just ignore people
and that's a lot of work they've come on
what have I the aim is to acquire as
many followers as possible and boost
your market value sabetha yo Mia
unfortunately if two models look alike
and one of them has a million followers
and the other just a thousand it's clear
who they'll book he could I so much I
you wait I work for a fashion magazine
and we have a casting agency in our
offices at castings the models presence
in social networks how many followers
they have plays a big roll labels pay
attention to whether the person has
influence beyond pooped on any muff get
low get low thermal cycler
the world's largest model agency elite
has adapted to this new situation
Booker's send clients profiles of the
models with notes on how successful they
are on social media disk appraisals
Cannavale won't let his listen before
there were social networks models
depended on a big family consisting of
press photographers fashion designers
the fashion scene and these people
decided whether a model had access to
the fashion world or not now things have
changed the models have taken things
into their own hands and their public is
decisive in their success I discover
effect asuka Mondesi defensive
vittoriosa British model Steven James is
successful and very media savvy under
contract with elite he's accumulated 1.8
million followers on Instagram alone
young Nigerian model davidson open a bow
is still far from such online popularity
in december 2016 he won elites
international model contest and now for
the first time he's part of the shows in
the fashion capitals Milan and Paris he
just opened and closed the show for
Versace in Milan that would be an honor
even if he weren't a newcomer
yeah pilot abysmal Sony much so she let
you guess by sonar aim now is to
establish his image and show him what
this profession involves oh yeah yeah
notes let's have a kiki having a good
face isn't enough to make you a big
model that's an elevated yeah you have
to learn how to behave toward the
various people in the business the
photographer is the designer go see too
late let evoke each other but also how
to deal with the social networks well
that many people don't know these things
they're new for them they have to learn
them let me to do like initials so
Davidson openable recently set up an
Instagram account and it seems to keep
calling out feed me he posts a mixture
of private snapshots and photo showing
his modeling work like here at the e se
me hace fashion show you're
instagramming a phase which should be
like for your walk walks you've done you
know it's kind of your selling points
it's what it's your brand that's your
brand if the Nutella is looking for
Davidson one of the two fastest ways you
can get to Davidson side ago today uses
facebook or go to davids Instagram the
post should look authentic but the
seemingly spontaneous snapshots need to
fulfill certain conditions
since apophis le i would like to post
pictures that convey moods or simply fun
long Buell's instagram is nothing
official but not all photos are suitable
this one for example isn't not because
the photos can be funny but you'd better
look good in them commit on my launch
command but I'm just wrong social
networks have empowered models to become
their own agents and have given them
greater influence that's especially true
for female models supermodel Cara
Delevingne has 50 million followers
while kendall jenner has more than a
hundred million sadly so far male models
can only dream of such numbers some come
on guys get posting